Now one of the most respected scientists
who was also a spiritualist was this gentleman here
who's doing some exercise in his home.
Sir Oliver Lodge.
Who very much pursued both electromagnetic research
and the study of spirits and telepathy
as two sides of the same coin.
He's today famous for being one of the pioneers
of radio. As well as inventing the spark plug
and the loud speaker.
So he invented the device called the "coherer"
which was like a simple electromagnetic wave detector.
And spent much of his later career
competing with Marconi in commercializing the radio.
And he was an active memberof the
SPR (Society for Psychical Research).
But he was very respected.
He gave a lot of public lectures. And he was seen as
this very very reliable scientific figure.
So when Frederic Myers, one of the founders of SPR
that we met earlier, decided to do an experiment
as he felt the end of his life was approaching.
He gave Lodge a sealed letter
that was only to be opened after Myers death.
And he was going to try to pass on a message
from beyond that was supposed to be matched
to the contents of the letter.
And it seemed like the experiment was successful.
In 1901 a group of women at the very highest level
of British society started receiving
messages from Myers
by "automatic writing." And at least according
to some interpretations
the messages matched the contents of  the letter
that Lodge had been given.
One of the key mediums was Alice Fleming on the left;
the sister of the famous writer Rudyard Kipling.
Alice co-authored some of Kipling's early Indian tales.
As a side note Kipling also wrote a great
short story called "The Wireless"
which is about contacting the afterlife with radio.
Another medium receiving messages from Myers
was Winifred Coombe Tennant, up there on the right.
Also a very remarkable woman.
A suffragist, a Member of Parliament and later
the British delegate to the League of Nations.
There were a few others as well.
And all the letters from Myers were shared
amongst this very elite group.
The hub of the group was the moustached gentleman
on the bottom left, Arthur Balfour,
who had been the president of SPR
and at the time when these letters were arriving
he was the Prime Minister of Britain.
And later he got the nickname "Bloody Balfour" for
cruelly putting down unrest in Northern Ireland.
And he was the one who signed the declaration to
found the state of Palestine. So a pretty important guy.
His brother Gerald in the middle
was equally accomplished.
And they had a third brother, Francis,
who died very young at the age of thirty,
many years before while climbing Mont Blanc.
And he was known for his talent in biology.
People said he would be the successor to Darwin.
But he died before he could realize that.
In any case this group
circulated all these letters arriving from Frederic Myers
from beyond, from the afterlife, via automatic writing.
And it was kind of shared hypertext, if you like.
They kept all this very secret.
and these letters were all interconnected
seemingly even though different people received them.
There were symbols that recurred
from classics from the Bible from Shakespeare
and so on. And there were so many interconnections
that ultimately the group became entirely convinced
that this was real.
This was Myers talking to them from the afterlife.
Other people started talking to them from the afterlife
including May Lyttelton who'd been sort of this lost love
of Arthur Balfour when he was young,
who had also died very young.
And also Francis Balfour, the third Balfour brother.
And there was this big picture this plan or
a story that started to emerge from the letters.
And so what Myers was saying
was that a kind of Darwinian evolution
continued in the afterlife. And
as Myers and Francis Balfour had entered the afterlife
they had gotten a lot smarter.
And there had been a sort of scientific revolution
in the afterlife.
People in the afterlife had perfected
the engineering of souls.
In fact Francis Balfour
was leading a team of spirit scientists
who were designing a perfect soul.
A sort of perfectly engineered spirit child
whose task would be to deliver humanity from chaos.
And of course this perfect soul only needed a vessel
to be incarnated into.
Now again a bit of context: this was 1912 at this point.
The British elite had this kind of widespread sense
of crisis approaching. Chaos in the world.
There were socialists and anarchists and feminists
and suffragists and sort of unrest in Europe. And all
these alliances unravelling.
So it was pretty clear that somebody
somebody needed to save the world.
So two members of this group,
Sir Arthur's living brother Gerald (in the middle)
and Winifred up on the right,
sort of took one for the team and they had an affair.
They were instructed by the spirits to have an affair.
And Winifred's much older husband actually
knew about it, but sort of maintained stiff upper lip
and said nothing about it.
And Winifred got pregnant and gave birth
to the vessel of this perfect engineered soul.
And I just can't help thinking how
remarkable this story is.
This is happening at the highest levels
of British politics and society
combining all these ideas about eugenics and evolution
and engineering
applied in this very otherworldly context.
So here is the spirit child.
At the age of one, and then at the age of thirty.
And he was called Henry Coombe-Tennant.
Born in 1913. And as far as we know
he wasn't the Messiah. He didn't save the world
from chaos unfortunately.
But he did have a pretty interesting life.
He studied in Cambridge.
He met Wittgenstein; taught by Ludwig Wittgenstein,
the famous philosopher.
Fought in World War II and got imprisoned.
Escaped a German prison camp by himself.
Fled across Europe.
Ended up working for the British intelligence service,
for MI6, together with Kim Philby
who would later be revealed as one of the most
one of the deepest Soviet moles,
double agents of all time.
And it was really Henry's life that kind of made me
decide that "Summerland" had to be a spy story.
He was an inspiration for one of the protagonists.
Now later on Henry's life sort of quieted down.
But in the 50s he did try to contact his mother,
Winifred, through a medium.
Probably to complain about the kind of
weird circumstances of his birth
or too high expectations.
And it's not clear if he succeeded.
But soon after that he did go away
to become a Catholic monk
and lived for the rest of his life in solitude. So...
It is actually the kind of biography
you can never put in fiction
because nobody would believe it.